cool so who here uses counterpart at
slip Fermo of the guru so you basically
know what this is already
but for the rest of you who don't know
so about me so I'm Marius I do data
stuff at flat on health and I work on
carnivores packaging all kinds of
horrible things so you know what white
what do we do this right so packaging is
hard and like modern sort of
particularly sort of data have heavy
applications use an enormous Li large
amount of libraries and these things
change all the time
and if you wait for you know Debian
stable to get your package I don't know
what the version of numpy on debian
stable is but I assume it's five or six
years old so that's not great so you
can't actually use or rely on sort of
traditional sort of system packages to
package your things for you so you know
now you have to compile it yourself
that's really hard so you know you don't
really want to go this alone so so
Connor Forge is the one-stop shop for
every single package that you may care
about so we package everything
regardless of platform on Macs Windows
Linux no arch and in the future some
more other fun things so the idea is
mostly and we don't and so Conda whilst
it is written in Python it doesn't just
package Python the package is everything
so you can condense tall bash and it
works you know I believe Anthony added
that the other day so you know so for
people that have been using it so some
new and the interesting events have
happened this past sort of Cup this past
year or so so kind of Forge is now an
unfocused fiscally sponsored project so
we you know we can actually afford to
pay for CI time so you know so that's
that's pretty great so we're part of non
focus I don't know why okay
and so we have robots now that do a lot
of work so so the robots have made lots
of pull requests we have like the
majority of Python 3.7 completed for
building and we're busy in the in the
giant migration cycle where we're sort
of recompiling the entirety of the
Condor forge stack we're about 30% of
the way down there mmm all right we're
about 40 okay so so we're about 40
percent of the way done but a lot of the
really hard stuff is done there's a so
we are using so we're using the
compilers built by by anaconda so there
has been in in this past year there's
been a you know an unfortunate
divergence they're sort of true to
primary conduct annals there is the
default channel maintained by anaconda
ink and us and previously you could sort
of have these two channels coexist
happily but it hasn't been that great in
the past year so a lot of the things
that we're doing now is trying to move
to merge the two these two things back
together and maintain sort of stability
and parity so that if you want to mix
the mix the channels together you can
and it's not gonna break for you doing
this is quite hard and we need to do
this very very carefully yeah somewhere
typically on the board with using GCC
for point eight and then the C++ API
change with GCC
45 point three five points you and so
that broke everything and so actors
anaconda Inc moved on and so those
packages
and unimportant play together so yeah
really yeah and the big reason for this
recom Paulo wrong recompilation is
basically GCC changed how they represent
in C++ standard : : string as you
imagine there's lots of C++ code out
there that uses a string and you
basically just broken sort of
compatibility with all of that if you if
you mix compilers so you can't do this
so and that's a large reason that's a
large reason why when things like CentOS
sent us five and six you can't use
packages between them
it's exactly it it is exactly the same
reason so but we're getting there I
don't know what's so you know so how do
you use this so if you have Conda
installed
you basically say Connor install - see
Connor Forge Cheadle and that will
install your ego I don't know how many
of you have tried to build GL yourself
it's effectively impossible so G doll is
the geospatial library and it's used
heavily by geospatial people and it is
actually a large part of the reason why
I can't afford exists is so counter
forts originated out of packaging very
hard to build - your special libraries
used heavily by sort of weather
prediction people in sort of out of the
UK Met Office and now it does everything
so if you want this as a default way
that you want to just use condor forge
to solve for all the packages so in your
condo RC you can add counter forge to
the channels the order here matters so
you probably want it above defaults so
you get things from us first because we
have slightly more packages so what is a
package you know but you know I can
install stuff with purpose it's like
yeah you can I mean it works pretty well
and it works a lot better than it used
to and it keeps getting better but you
know can you put them store those things
I don't think so
you can totally content store them and
they work just fine so the idea is that
like counter forts packages a thought
extends the packaging sort of space from
beyond just these vendor specific tools
because you know the the problem is not
as modern applications or big polyglot
things encompassing many languages and
using lots of different things all
together in concert and you need a
holistic way to be able to install all
of that together safely and know that it
works and so far you know you can
carefully build a docker container it'll
probably work or you can use contact
which effectively does mostly the same
thing so for people that want to find
slide this is how you do exact
reproducibility so if you care about
making a condo environment and taking it
and being able to put that thing down
exactly on on another platform so the
first one is that'll give you a
canonical thing but will still that will
still invoke invoke the solver the
second line there will give you an
explicit thing that'll give you a set of
packages that are basically just URLs in
topological order that will be installed
in that sequence if you do that then you
don't need a docker file anymore
so you can basically get exact
reproducibility of your of of any
content of any environment installed
entirely with content this works really
well and it means you basically have an
alternative to something like the
followed lock but for every single
package that is packaged that is
packaged with kondeh
this is not just can't afford this is
just how condor works
and alternatively if you want to turn
these into installers you should
probably take a look look at condor
packets which is a really really
fantastic piece of technology as well so
you know this stuff is great you know
but you have a bunch of what if you want
to send your own stuff right all of us
probably have some library that we care
about or our maintainer love that we'd
like to package and we'd like you we'd
like it to make it easy for users to use
this stuff so you know so basically we
have a we have a we have a whole bunch
of repositories and kind of Forge
there's a repository called staged
recipes she fought the Reaper make pull
request make the robots happy and
there's a better one here so firstly
make sure that if the package already
exists you know you probably don't need
to do something because it exists so
you're right a condor recipe will go
into your but evolve like key components
there that matter make a pull request
eight recipes then the pool then the
robots kick in do a bunch of testing and
so one of the big things that that's
interesting about can't afford is during
this phase here we have a team of human
reviewers that are going to look at this
and say yeah this is fine or we it's
like this is a really great package we'd
love to have it but we need like some
minor tweaks to this recipe in order for
it to sort of meet the standards of
packaging in our in our community we'd
like things to be both you know fairly
nicely and you know we have some sort of
fairly gentle constraints of like what
we accept and won't accept and then so
once once there's a repository it gets
pushed around a counter org and you know
and then you as a human making that has
made this package canal sort of do
maintenance on it all the robots will do
a bunch of work
so you know what so if you want if you
make a condo kind of package what does
that entail so you basically you make a
metal Takayama file and I'm gonna say
and these are sort of generally
important bits it's that we care about
so you have a bold you'll have a bold
section that has a bold number that will
be zero you can sort of skip it for
things that it doesn't work on so you
know say your thing doesn't work on Mac
and you know don't build it for Mac
we're in where Microsoft now they'll
work on Windows don't worry about it
this is how you should run poop if you
were at Steve if you are at Steve Dara's
talk this is how you should run - things
with - em so this ensures that your that
that pup will run correctly on Windows
and you will run the right path and
there's a bunch of magic orgs that we
don't care about so because Condor tends
to sort of circumvent how install things
we don't actually want to put this off
we want you to tell us what your thing
needs so your package has requirements
so Conda has sort of three sets of
requirements now it used to be - so
there's been a in a sort of slight
difference in how these things are
specified if you if you haven't done
this recently so Connor used to have two
sections called bolt and run the section
that used to be called bold is now
basically called host for practical
purposes and there's a new section
called bolt that is basically new and
essentially so if you have a package it
has a bunch of see dependencies or it
has it has a CX engine you'll tell her
you'll tell it I need to have a compiler
around and I need some special
compilation tools that those sections
all go in bold if you if you have things
of I need to run Python and I need pup
and I need like open SSL and some weird
special thing on Windows because you
know old versions of Windows don't have
proper intz for some reason sure go
ahead those things and then my my thing
requires Python to run and so these are
sort of some of the some of the core
components that you would need in your
recipe we have extensive guides
you this sort of more in-depth on condor
forage itself there's a big example
recipe that has like lots of sections
and comments on like these little bets
that matter this is what you should fill
in and also you you should probably take
a look at one of the several thousand
report of recipes that we already have
because odds are there is a package that
is quite similar to the thing you want a
package and if you want to take a look
at how somebody else has done it the
wisdom of the crowds is extremely
extremely valuable here and there's a
little extra section there so that we
have is in the at the very bottom over
your two of your recipe you say there's
a recipe maintainer and that's your name
so if you put your getup name on there
you basically when this process happens
that we sort of outlined here you become
a maintainer and I've commit rights to
that repository that sort of spawns from
there and you can help sort of keep that
thing in keep that recipe up to date and
if if new things new versions or fancy
new features come out you can do that so
you don't need to wait on anybody else
to get that done so there's a lot of
things that go into maintaining a large
ecosystem right so so pond affords
itself maintains a big set of sort of
pens
so I'm just going to quickly follow this
link Oh God
I've lost control of the computer so
essentially we have a set of constraints
that we apply so essentially we want to
build ignore the very bits at the top so
there's a whole bunch of packages that
we've been identifying as things that
have that cause compatibility problems
if you sort of just casually change
their versions so basically you can just
say I require B zip and we're gonna save
cool we're gonna use bezel version 1 in
internally what that's what that means
is we're gonna use B's version 1 and
then there's a section up here at the
top where we'll say oh these are version
1 less than 2 so all of that stuff is
basically handled for you and you don't
actually need to care too much as a
package author and the whole the whole
idea is there is by you by us evolving
this section here we can affect
large-scale change on the entire
ecosystem of packages that we build
whilst maintaining compatibility across
the cross sort of several thousand
packages like getting this right is you
may notice there's a whole bunch of
weird stuff here if you if you are
familiar with with how with house or
selectors work we're actually using some
of the stuff now - as also sort of
migratory flags so we can selectively
opt in into some of these versions for
for certain things so that we can so
gradually and sort of deliberately move
an ecosystem forward rather than needing
to do sort of Big Bang kind of upgrades
so so we do this with a lot of tools
can't afford just basically automation
on automation so our primary schools
called Candace Murphy so that is our
tool for bolding feedstocks and so that
that tool itself goes and looks at your
recipe because look it looks at the meta
document and looks at a bull config that
you can place optionally it goes and
looks at that global pinning
configuration and then it splits out a
whole bunch of files that various CI
services understand
so it'll spit out a file the Travis CI
understands it'll spit out a fire file
that a pair understands one that circle
understands and very very soon one that
one that can be understood by agile
pipelines so and then does this and
generates a lot of these sort of support
configuration files so let me quickly
show what what what one of those looks
like so this feedstock itself is this
repository is itself a condor Forge
package and it's got a little little
file here that says I have these
constraints that I that I get imposed on
and you should not change these things
yourself at all that is a bad idea but
it is useful to look and see is like
what is actually going to happen when
when I run my when I run my application
so
so you know kind of for jism is a very
large organization at this point so
we've built over a hundred twenty
thousand artifacts there's about four
hundred fifty gigabytes of artifacts we
have more than five thousand feedstocks
and every feedstock is a repository on
github we have over a thousand
maintained errs on these and we've made
more than 40,000 pull requests that is a
scale that is like complicated so
dealing with uh sort of organizationally
in is is non-trivial so so through this
year we've actually sort of formalized
and established actual processes for you
know carnivores is a large organization
and we have a core team of about 17
people and seven feet seventeen people
can very rarely get to any form of sort
of unanimous decision approach it
doesn't actually work to get you know
for consensus is a is a bad decision
strategy when you have more than I think
three people so you need a way to make
decisions so we've actually basically
worked through a lot of things of like
making decisions is important you may be
aware of the fact that Guido van Rossum
has sort of stepped down as the PSF so
making decisions it turns out is a thing
that Python communities are figuring out
how to do now
so we basically we've went an
established like look we need a way to
make decisions and we've started using
these things and all our decisions are
for the most part public where there can
be certain things are not basically
things like inducting new members votes
aren't public but for a lot of the stuff
you can actually see us vote on issues
sort of in public and you know once
things pause stuff will typically happen
and we also have a sort of a project
where people can submit enhancement
proposals for how we can do big things
better for sort of like doing
large-scale changes to the ecosystem so
we've got a couple of teams so
the core team there's a whole bunch of
people here you'll probably see us on
github somewhere we cover a lot of
places see James looks weird because
reasons and then we have an additional
team that is a superset of that is
mostly a superset of the other one and
the these are all individuals that will
review recipes as they land in the stage
recipes typically sort of a recipe
that's that lands and staged recipes
will sort of reviewed within about like
two or three days and you know depending
on the complexity will either land
roughly at the same time or require some
more somewhere fine-tuning of add
something complicated so we do BOTS we
believe very very heavily in automation
for everything so we have three sort of
main big BOTS that do our work so we
have a little bot where the web services
part and then we have the Condor Ford's
tick pot that we basically put all the
rest of the functionality into so so
when you go to condor Forge so let's go
to an actual feed stock so I go to
counter forage staged recipes I get a
pull request and I open a random pull
request of any kind it's all been made a
thing okay let's go see what's all ended
so so so then he made a pull request
it's got some code he didn't really tell
us what it is but yeah we trust Sylvain
it's fine but the bot has done some work
the bot is taking a look at this thing
and said hey this is visiting service
you know everything's fine
you don't need to worry and generally
that's what the part is gonna say unless
it doesn't in which case it's probably
gonna tell you hey I found something
wrong here's how you fix it
so in this case he's made a recipe it's
got a metal yeah Mille sorry really
thanks get up so he's he has a recipe
and this is basically what every single
sort of written what a lot of basic
recipes looks like so you'll see it's
the same sort of template pattern this
thing his thing is no arch bison which
is a special kind of Python so it's a
Python that that content knows
especially how to deal with an install
that doesn't actually require us to do a
lot of old work so he needs a modern
Python and some other things and
something like that yeah and so and we
we'd like to have we'd like to see
licenses and things like that so that we
we do a lot of these things safely
we have the web services part so in a
lot of the pull requests you will see
several members of of our team basically
talk to this counter for admin and I'll
ask it very kindly to go to settings the
bot will then pick up and do the thing
you like you very kindly asked it to go
to there's a bunch of commands that are
synthetic that are listed there you can
go look up the complete list the most
important ones are basically those two
typically the only one that we tend to
actually use these days kind of Forge is
please rerender so if you've made a sort
of structural change to your recipe say
you know you realize oh I have some
compiled code now I've added a compiler
or I've added one of these things that
that that exists in the counter for
spinning basically you need to tell the
bot hey I made a change go take care of
this for me and then the bottle basic
you say go take a look and say you see
if there's work to be done if there is
it'll make a commit to that to that
feedstock pull request our BOTS make
commits we are BOTS do not just comment
because you know I don't want my pot to
tell me what work needs to be done I
wanted to just do the work so and that
brings us to the ticker slash rebuild
bot so the ticket robot is it's great
it's like drastically changed changed my
workflow and under forge as most east
bank
thanks to CJ that CJ over there he's
done like an incredible job with it so
initially what this bought was what the
spot is is you know when you make a
package and you when you release a new
version of your your thing you push it
up ipi or some other packaging in
infrastructure you'd like new packages
to be built for it you don't really want
to be bothered with a hassle of like
going to condom for it and say hey I
released 5.4 not to wear as I had five
dot 4.1 previously so you know let's
take the human drudgery out of this
robots can watch this thing and you know
when you release a new package the robot
will say hey you released a new package
I think let me go make a poorer
and then our various CI will kick in see
if it builds and had built successfully
the new as a maintainer can go hit the
green button and say yeah this is all
cool and this all happens all the time
so the what what has made lots of pull
requests at this point it basically runs
every hour and does like you know and as
mostly automated a lot of the general
sort of like keeping count affords up to
date which was sort of historically a
bit of a problem where such packages
that didn't really have sort of maintain
the reactive maintainer that wanted to
keep them up to date you know they
didn't so they were languishing and now
we we've largely automated a lot of that
that stuff of like no the package on
can't afford is going to be as recent as
the version on anything else that's the
idea I mean we're building a lot of
fancy other stuff so so we're building
some things about fancy artifacts
searching so we have a full knowledge of
every artifact that kind of forges ever
produced and we built indexes for that
so if you as a user want to know I have
a thing that's failing because I
couldn't find live food s oh what the
hell gives me live food out there so
it's like this is this is a this is a
remarkably intractable problem for
something that should be simple and we
can tell this now so we can say oh you
should install that thing and then you
can we can also do the inverse now so
whereas you whereas you've specified the
requirements that your package needs
maybe it's useful for you to know what
uses your package so inverting this
inverting the dependency graph and
saying you know so I'm I'm an author of
our package
what other things use me because it's
very interesting to see what the sort of
general ecosystem structure is of you
know all packages that use each other
and you can also you can ask sort of a
whole bunch of other sort of interesting
sort of global questions about all the
packages inside a counterforce graph and
you can go find some
we're literally scary strange code at-at
regress Islip CF Lib which is you know a
terrible name so we're in the process of
adding more build capacity hopefully a
lot more but sort of for the immediate
pain we're gonna sort of try and fix up
our at their cue so it's not really as
bad and long anymore and we're working
with with Microsoft on getting sort of
agile pipelines so ready to roll out for
lots of counter forge so we can sort of
run at a much much greater scale and
have far faster response and feedback
for things and then if any of you were
in in in in microcoulombs talk you saw
some crazy stuff with webassembly
and you know Connor Forge wants to
package that so it's going to be an
interesting challenge for sure but
there's it so so packaging things for
webassembly
holding things sore arm turns out you
know
turns out phones are pretty powerful
CPUs these days and they get put into
servers now and they've required no
power so these things are sort of coming
into the market is very inexpensive ways
to do computing and then sort of we want
to build out a subset of things are sort
of PowerPC as well because
supercomputers are still a thing and you
know and so tomorrow we're gonna have a
hands-on session where several the
counterforce core team will be available
to sort of help you with some packaging
questions or if you just want something
packaged or you just want to hang out
and talk to us you know think of this is
sort of like office hours tutorial hour
and we're gonna do some sprints on
Sunday to make all the stuff even better
so any questions
we track the tendencies versus packages
you actually have support change
[Music]
installed
yeah I believe that is tracked right now
so so the one thing that you can't get
is remove things that I didn't
explicitly ask for something like that I
mean it's gonna move your dependencies
to ensure compatibility but so soon
right so yeah so
and this there's a common history in
there yeah I mean you should probably
the solver right now does actually
remove packages from the insulation if
they're no longer required like that is
actually in already it doesn't happen
that much in in the current case because
it sort of it takes the current set of
packages that you have as the state that
it wants that it wants to keep so
basically if you tell it you have an
initial if you tell it you have a
different initial state than it what it
actually has then it will actually
remove things but right now it's not
quite there
we have another question actually go
move on and you guys can continue this
afterwards maybe okay yeah so I know it
Elmo fizzes on oh okay either way so I
know with some package of solutions like
if you want to like recreate a
particular environment you can make like
a Debian distro and have your own
distribution pulls everything in so you
can recreate your save environment but
your actual package is empty it's just
listen whole bunch of the pen sees and
sometimes people do that same thing with
like requirements at txt s is that a
common usage that you see with I can't
afford or somebody would define their
own particular packages just for their
environment and ends up not really
requiring a source code because it's
strictly used for dependencies and is
that something you think would work good
in a workflow so as for some kind of
force so counter force uses meta
packages which is basically that sort of
idea of your package that only that only
sort of specifies runtime requirements
what sort of run time constraints and
can enforce those we use those fairly
selectively for things so I can
definitely see that there is value in a
service like that that's probably can't
afford adjacent as for hosting there's
those packages inside Condor forge
itself there are some problems with that
exact that's exactly one of them yeah
and I think I wrote it it is an
interesting use case and like I can
definitely see that see that there is a
model where
you have you know a smaller sort of like
org level side repository that has like
I need these things and here are the
channels I care about that kind of that
kind of model you can do that and set
that up yourself very very easily as for
counter forge hosting that for you
probably know but like sort of a side
thing that that lives not in the corner
for primary channel that's quite
feasible
Oh probably just were naive one I never
done that before and that have a package
that is heavily dependent on see which I
not super nervous to give on this anyway
long story how would try to make a dry
dry run first
you know Pru I mean I would honestly
recommend you make a PR like so we have
we have automation that all build it for
you in a whole bunch of environments
that you don't necessarily have access
to I don't know if you have an OS X and
a Windows and a Linux machine available
most people don't so it's probably just
actually a good idea to just make the PR
if it fails it's fine like you know PRS
like that's what c is for right CI is
there to fail so that you know about
this so I would I would honestly say
it's like if you have a sort of scary C
C kind of thing go look at like some of
our sort of fairly fairly big C packages
so you know if it's something so big and
complicated find something similar if
it's something so basic like you know
like bash bash is simple so it's like
it's got a pretty effectively calls a
dot dot forward says configure make may
consult and a lot of this stuff is like
that and you basically find a recipe
that sort of matches that kind of
structure you can come tomorrow and you
can come tomorrow and we can help you as
well
yeah
[Applause]